hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the genome and 3d the
clinical biomarker platform presented by
Kevin little he's the chief scientific
officer at 3d signatures and Corporation
I am Marjorie Torres elaborate and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries labyrinths is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
org
at the bottom or center of your screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits chat located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
bombs of buses to change your credits
please join me in welcoming dr. Kevin
little I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you very much and I'd
like to just say thank you to lab roots
for inviting me to speak at this
molecular diagnostics event it really is
a pretty fascinating opportunity to be
delivering this kind of material through
a new portal because I think a lot of
what I'd like to introduce to people
today is this idea of the adoption of
new technologies into what we're doing
particularly bringing some fundamental
biology into clinical practice so on
that note thanks everyone for for
joining today I'll just quickly provide
a little bit of the disclosures here as
mentioned I am the chief scientific
officer of 3d signatures I'm also a an
independent consultant with my own
consultancy but
primarily what I'm gonna do today is try
and speak a little bit to some some
fundamentals in biology as opposed to
anything with a deliberately corporate
bent to it and so what I would really
like folks to be able to take away from
this today is is maybe just an
appreciation for the fact that I think
we're on the cusp of beginning to
appreciate some new approaches to health
in terms of what we traditionally
thought about as genomics be the one I'm
gonna spend this time talking about is
probably some more fundamental
historical aspects to just giving a
understanding of the basic biology
between genetics and the genome and how
I think that's going to lead into some
really exciting opportunities for not
just my company but for a whole range of
different types of approaches to new
clinical action and so bear with me a
little bit in that I it might get a
little bit textbook ish at times but
what I'm gonna try and do is introduce
some concepts that I think make it as
far as just how far we've come in terms
of the biology and end the genome in and
in saying that really it's this
difference between the traditional kind
of static two-dimensional view we have
towards genomics versus what really is
much more of a dynamic movement through
three dimensions and I use a good
analogy if you think about a microscope
image of a slide first or of a cell
rather on a slide versus being able to
delve into a living organism you're
really getting a bit of this analogy
like looking down from a satellite view
on a Tesla Factory it's a very different
understanding you get from that
two-dimensional map view than if you
were actually inside the living breed
where you have all sorts of different
channels and products and the movement
of materials in and out through
corridors and that's a dynamic process
that takes place over time that's really
what I'm trying to introduce as being a
relevant concept in medicine that to be
honest I think a lot of us are either
ignoring or really being negligent and
bringing into the important clinical
practices that we need to I'll start
just briefly talking about genomics
because I think it's been a pretty
powerful buzzword over the last well 18
years now for those folks who've been
around long enough to remember in 2000
there was a lot of fanfare around the
announcement that the human genome had
been sequenced and that these two sort
of competing collaborating groups
meeting up at the White House to
announce this this real landmark event
in the application of human technology
to cracking the code and this led to a
whole number of different types of
analysis and what was meant to be an
entirely new way of treating disease and
I think in those intervening 18 years
probably very few of us have actually
had our genomes and I suspect even fewer
of us have had any genomic information
be something that has come into play and
influencing a personalized approach to
our own care so as much as the promise
is very important I think there's still
been quite a bit of work in terms of
bringing that into practice that that
leads really into some of the
discussions I want to bring in today
about a new view towards genomics so
what I mentioned about it being a little
textbook II if you bear with me I I
think part of that approach to genomics
and health really comes from
a historical view that a number of
groups even as far back as the mid
eighteen hundreds with Gregor Mendel
beginning to look at trying to identify
the the underlying basis for inheritance
the inheritance of characteristics and
Mendel and others really looked at
organisms and tried to identify and even
predict how traits could be inherited so
Mendel was crossing pea plants and and
was able to predict what would happen in
subsequent generations even though he
didn't have an understanding of the
cause of that inheritance
others such as Bovary really then began
to look at that more not at the organism
level but at the cellular level and
we're able to identify that there are
molecules within a cell that seemed to
move in association with changes in how
a cell behaves how cells differentiate
from earlier stages into more
specialized States and even and the
progression into disease so when groups
such as mothers and beginning to see
that that could lead to B onset of
cancer there was some understanding that
there was a mechanism underneath there
that was leading to this inheritance of
the mutation Barbara McClintock began to
look at how genetic elements could be
recombined within maize plants we get
down even further into a level of detail
with the work that Watson and Crick did
really using Rosalind Franklin's x-ray
crystallography on on DNA to do a
breakthrough in 1953 and elucidate the
structure of DNA and that leads more and
more into what we're seeing today as far
as DNA sequencing becoming readily
available so we're moving from this the
work in inheritance from an organism
down to a cell down to a large
macromolecule and even down to
individual DNA base pairs and that's
really this rig
ducks honest approach to understanding
genomics what you see here on the right
is that they're now today even since
since 2000 now a whole variety of
companies producing industrial-scale
platforms for DNA sequencing even more
companies using those technologies to
develop new kinds of tests and
applications for sequencing all the way
through to direct-to-consumer companies
that can try and tailor lifestyle change
based on a genome profile or even help
you trace your your family history so
genomics has become very much a
reductionist approach and I think that
really is will be a two dimensional view
again the technologies that have been
brought into clinical practice I would
argue are a two dimensional approach as
well traditionally cytogenetics and
karyotyping will look at chromosomal
aberrations large rearrangements in
individual chromosomes or changes in
copy numbers of chromosomes there are
array technologies that will look at
changes in the levels of expression of
genes or copy numbers and genes and the
DNA sequencing technologies that have
evolved from the early saying or
labeling methods all the way through to
some of those technologies I mentioned
earlier but fundamentally DNA sequencing
as it is today is really a process where
you effectively squeeze DNA out of a
cell break it up into a multitude of
pieces to build a library and then go
about trying to sequence those
individual fragments and piece the
jigsaw puzzle back together again and
that in my view really avoids looking at
some of the importance of the biology
and the dimensions so if we get into
talking about a three-dimensional
biology and a nucleus I'll briefly
remind those folks who haven't been in a
genetics class for a while of this
central dogma of molecular biology
basically says you have DNA RNA
and protein DNA being the
double-stranded blueprint molecule
inside the nucleus that undergoes a
process to copy itself replication
before a cell will divide but the
information in the DNA makes its way
into proteins which are the structural
functional elements in the cells through
this intermediary RNA and so there are
processes in the nucleus to transcribe
the DNA into RNA so that the RNA can
then leave the nucleus enter into the
cytoplasm and run as a template for the
assembly of proteins that's been the
central dogma that's still a very
effective way for us to think about it
over the last twenty or thirty years an
enormous amount of works been done to
identify some additional elements that
happen along the sides some other types
of modulating elements or forms of RNA
that that transmit information
differently but effectively the central
dogma still stands you think about a
nucleus or the DNA is housed and somehow
magically that information leads into
assembly of proteins but within that
nucleus the DNA itself has to be really
tightly compressed and a lot of the
early work and even today a lot of
pathology work effectively looks at a
DNA nucleus and the degree of staining
in there as a way of looking at how the
the DNA content is managed and one thing
I think we have come to appreciate is
just how tightly packaged it does have
to become to fit into such a constrained
space so quickly if a DNA double helix
is two nanometers wide that has to fit
into a cell nucleus that's about a
thousand times wider but really if you
were to take every single chromosome in
a human cell and line that DNA up and
end it's about two meters long so we're
talking about a degree of compressing
this molecule a million times its length
into a very confined space so packaging
DNA becomes something that I think we
often times for
in the sequencing world can have a
pretty significant effect on what goes
on as far as the gene expression and so
a cell spends most of its time in a
phase called interphase we often think
of chromosomes in DNA as these nice
tight little X's that you saw in the
previous slide these meta phases but in
fact the DNA isn't active in that that's
that's the suitcase into which DNA is
packaged so that the cell can divide but
really the active phase of a cell is
interphase and in that as bovary and
others have been able to witness down
microscopes for decades
it's a tangle or a mass the DNA is d
condensed and pretty much occupies the
whole space in the nucleus and that
becomes really interesting from the
standpoint of understanding the function
of that DNA something else is important
to just know the cell cycle is this
arrangement where their cell spends most
of its time in this interphase living
and expressing its DNA and then it has a
couple of what we call checkpoints so
areas where there are inherent
mechanisms in the cell that can identify
damage to DNA and go about assembling
factories of proteins to repair that
damage or to trigger the cell to die if
the damage is deemed to be too too grave
for the organism and so these cell cycle
checkpoints end up being the targets of
most therapies and so we'll see a little
bit later that the cell cycle and that
and the checkpoints influence a lot of
the functionality within a cell y
functional form and function come
hand-in-hand in most things and I think
in cells as well but we have a lesser
degree of appreciation of that and you
probably should again we think about the
X's of metaphase chromosomes but folks
over the last probably
twenty-five years have really began to
try to understand how this deep
condensed interphase the chromatin which
is the combination of DNA and proteins
could be something that influences or at
least makes a non-random form of
expression of a genome one other thing I
think we need to begin to appreciate as
we look at a nucleus and and how it
functions within a cell is to also be
aware that the cells themselves have a
whole network of support structures that
are quite dynamic think of it as a
series of kind of scaffolding and shock
absorbers because the cell doesn't exist
in isolation so all sorts of pressures
happen and in the external environment
of a cell that end up rearranging the
components that are inside the cell and
that includes the nucleus the image that
you see here on the right is really the
idea that while we have to appreciate
this lattice work or framework in two
dimensions we need to even begin to
imagine how the repercussions of some of
those dynamics happen in a volume space
of a network in in a three-dimensional
nucleus the traditional view of these
interphase nuclei of the D condensed
active DNA has often been referred to as
a bowl of spaghetti but much of the work
that's come on with the advent of some
new technologies particularly with
spectral karyotyping where you can begin
to very colorfully stain each individual
chromosome leads to these kinds of
images of identifying these chromosome
territories and what becomes really
exciting now with chromosome territory
work is thus appreciation for though
these are distinct chromosomes how do
they begin to interact with each other
and the video you're about to see shows
a nice image of these are mouse
embryonic stem cells where each
chromosome has been painted
front color but earnest Lau's group in
the UK in the last year have been able
to demonstrate through a series of
pretty complex modeling again using a
two-dimensional technology they've built
this three-dimensional model so the
video you're about to see will show them
effectively artificially pulling the
individual chromosome territories apart
and I think that gives us a bit of an
appreciation as you're gonna watch the
video to see how each of these
individual chromosomes actually does
have some degree of interaction with
other chromosomes around it so we'll
watch the video now
so this idea of chromosome territories
being areas that can actually interact
really has led to some some pretty
fundamental work in understanding
exactly how the structure influences the
function and vice versa and I mentioned
earlier these chromatin chromosome
territories and the interaction you can
imagine that the Sun as you saw that
animation some individual loops of DNA
from neighboring chromosomes can
actually co-localize and that's become
some pretty fundamental work that's gone
on in the last 15 or so years by a few
groups that have begun to map out some
of these interactions the reason why we
say they're functionally important is
because what's been identified through
groups such as Wendy Bickmore Thomas
tele Thomas Kramer they've really done
some fantastic work in showing how the
functional aspects in the cell cycle
when DNA becomes replicated when it is
transcribed into RNA or when it is
repaired the protein machinery that's
required to do those things has to gain
access to the DNA and that's why it's
happening in a deep condensed interphase
nucleus but that that those protein
machines assemble into effectively
factories or aggregates where loops of
DNA from neighboring cells are all kind
of brought together into this this one
cluster it's really a cell has figured
out the Industrial Revolution long
before we did it managed to very
efficiently do all of these biological
processes it needed by bringing a number
of areas of chromosomes together in one
area now that can of course lead to a
few problems as you can imagine if all
of this DNA is undergoing functions such
as replication transcription repair one
of the other interesting things that are
in Slough is group has been able to show
with this same modeling technique is I
thing for the first time a really
wonderful 3d visualization that gets us
to understand not only how these
chromosome territories can overlap each
other but as you'll see in this next
video the difference between the areas
that are expressed and not expressed the
work over several decades showing
changes in gene expression in
two-dimensional images often suggested
that at certain genes more towards the
periphery of a nucleus would be silenced
those sometimes closer to the center of
the nucleus were more actively expressed
but that wasn't always the case and
people have really scratched their heads
I think for some time to understand why
in some instances you can watch a cell
type differentiate into a more
specialized cell type and the positions
of two chromosome territories for
instance chromosome 18 and chromosome 19
could radically change as that cell
became more specialized whereas in other
instances chromosome territories
wouldn't change at all it's become a
very difficult thing to deduce from a
two-dimensional image what we begin to
appreciate here in the animations that
Ernst Lau's group shows us is the
silenced area is associated with the
nuclear lamin or that's periphery are
the the yellowish areas whereas in blue
it's the more active areas and as you
watch the video and you watch these
territories be kind of artificially
pulled apart we begin to appreciate how
this is a whole network of channels it's
almost a block of Swiss cheese if you
can imagine with a number of of access
points so that the protein machinery the
RNA transcripts can flow through pores
in the membrane of the nucleus through
different levels and depths to to
penetrate the areas that are needed for
the replication transcription or repair
of DNA so just watch that video analysis
exactly how complex the
three-dimensional aspects of the nucleus
are I think one other thing that is
helpful to appreciate is just how kind
of violent some of these processes are
and that helps us understand the the
difficulty of these protein machines
accessing the the genes and the areas of
chromosomes they need to the the
animation here shows DNA replication so
you can see the DNA coming in from the
left into these helicase and isomerize
enzymes and polymerases where the the
leading strand of DNA flowing off to the
right goes directly through whereas the
lagging strand being copied up at the
top really requires a quite a bit of
contortionism
so this is replication happening in one
spot you can imagine over on the right
hand side the linear image down at the
bottom really shows that this
replication happens at a number of
positions along a linear chromosome but
imagine the looping and the condensation
required to have a number of different
replication factories all within a
nucleus the same time I really like anit
to a construction site imagine where
you've got an entire complex being built
by a number of construction teams doing
a similar job in different rooms or
different areas and I'm just imagining
the dynamics between those groups if
you've got the the banging noises and
the shaking movements happening from a
group in one room next to you imagine
this nucleus with thousands of these
replication factories all trying to be
commissioned and decommissioned at the
same time in conjunction and it really
leads to I think a much better
understanding of just what a dynamic
process it is going on in the nucleus
and so with that brief overview
how things are being organized and how
we're really beginning to understand
more and more about the functionality
I'd like to then just briefly talk about
what I see as being some of the
opportunities and some of the
technologies that are appreciating this
this three-dimensional organization and
how that's being brought into the clinic
fundamentally cancer itself is a disease
of genomic instability and that means
that the genome becomes increasingly
deregulated or recombined and that in
two-dimensional sequencing that means
we're identifying particular mutations
variations in the numbers of a copy of
an individual gene or other elements
microsatellite instability x' faults
with repair enzymes that lead to
telltale signs of DNA sequence changes
but really that's again a
two-dimensional view to genomic
stability and what some groups including
ours are doing is really beginning to
try and identify ways of establishing
signatures or particular measures that
can show the difference between healthy
cells and diseased cells for instance or
the risk for progression of a disease as
well as responses to therapy and I think
that's where three-dimensional genome
organization and functionality can
really begin to be brought into the
clinic so some of those technologies
include things such as gene therapy
applications and so the work that I did
with a group during my PhD was really
looking at the concept of gene targeting
and that was one way to begin to map out
this functional organization within
three dimensions if you were to
introduce a linear ectopic gene
targeting molecule so a single strand or
a double strand of DNA but a linear
molecule into a cell nucleus the cells
machinery actually recognizes that as
being damaged DNA it sees
broken DNA ends and it looks for a way
to repair that through a process of
recombination if we are to tag one end
of that molecule with half of a gene for
instance it's gonna go in and try and
seek out the other half of the gene if
that's in the genome so it will go in
and through a process of recombination
through this repair machinery the rest
of the DNA sequence will be copied onto
the end of that molecule so you'll have
half the gene which is something you can
select for with a drug for instance if
you're doing this in cell culture what
we did through our work in gene mapping
was really to be able to show how
introducing one of these molecules to
find the spot in the genome could show
that it would copy that sequence and
then it would go and integrate into a
break somewhere nearby that's what the
DNA repair machinery was doing and that
really led to mapping out the
interaction between the site where the
sequence was being copied and the other
sites being brought into that same
repair factory and that meant either
some areas that were on the same
chromosome but relatively close by as
you see on the right or incompletely
distinct chromosomes and so this was
some of the early work showing that this
functional mapping that the
three-dimensional aspects of the genome
really mattered when it came to the
function and the influence on DNA I
think with the advent of some of the new
microscopy technologies particularly
three-dimensional microscopy being
brought closer and closer to digital
pathology into clinical practice that's
really where we're beginning to have a
much better appreciation for the
importance of this in disease for
instance here you have a prostate cancer
cell that's been labeled with
immunohistochemistry x' for cytokeratin
a green labeling the Dappy staining is
the DNA in the nucleus and then we've
also tagged the tips of the chromosomes
the telomeres with a fish probe and
that's the type of technology that we're
applying with 3d signatures telomeres
are these
you can think of them often as the
plastic caps on the ends of your
shoelaces that stop your shoelace from
fraying and unwinding and effectively
that's what a telomere is is a sequence
of repeated DNA that makes sure the cell
doesn't recognize a chromosome as a
broken end that needs to be repaired and
so the work that Elizabeth Blackburn and
Carol Greider did that led to the
identification of feeling airs in the
discovery of the enzyme that can copy
those really was fundamentally showing
that telomere biology is a good marker
for I think genomic configuration and
stability in the work that our
co-founder dr. sabina mine has done over
the years has shown how the
dysregulation of telomere biology is
something that can be mapped out in
genomic stability we've begun to look at
profiling cells by comparing the
position the content of telomeres as a
proxy for the overall position and
content of the genome in three
dimensions so we do that through 3d
microscopy but also through software
analytics again these are some of the
new technologies that I think need to be
brought into clinic and the kinds of
things that we are being able to measure
really are much more informative than a
two dimensional aspect we're beginning
to catch a relative position of
chromosomes within the three-dimensional
space even the leader of begin to think
about the position of all of the the
telomeric signals in a nucleus the
degree to which those are compressed or
expand it actually becomes a sign for
how quickly cells are dividing and so
this really begins to lead into some of
the major indices and indicators of
cancer where does that lead us next is
really where I want to finish and I
think this idea that the 3d biology that
I've tried to
line a little bit today really is is
neglected in the kinds of testing that's
going on and the kinds of thinking that
we're doing with sequencing more so
genomics is a field that despite the
technology being something that's been
readily available for a long time with
2d sequencing the barriers to adoption
of that in medicine are much more than
technological barriers and as we branch
into this new area of appreciating the
importance of three-dimensional biology
I think we can probably leapfrog some of
the challenges that 2d sequencing has
had by addressing some of those barriers
to adoption I had a very interesting
conversation with a colleague just today
and looking at some of these whole
genome sequencing initiatives that have
gone on in a number of countries in the
last few years the UK the US and Canada
has one as well and what they're finding
is that even though the cost of
sequencing a whole genome is down to
let's say a thousand dollars and even
some people project down to about a
hundred dollars the next couple of years
we can gain access to someone's entire
genome sequence but what are the costs
of making that actionable information
and so anecdotally my colleague was
referring to one of these whole genome
sequencing projects there were they just
had some very interesting information
both in cost as well as in actionable
the some of the sequence mutations that
they were finding in people they
expected these people should have but
telltale signs of diseases that have
been associated mutations and lo and
behold these people are fine so the
two-dimensional sequence mutations there
but the people don't have the disease
that they're expected to have and
likewise it might cost a thousand
dollars to sequence a genome but the
costs of implementing that into the care
system the number of professionals that
need to be consulted to bring the
patient into the picture is on the scale
of a hundred thousand dollars and so
we're really talking about some
significant barriers to adoption for
these technology
that I think companies like ours
researchers that are involved in this
translational space really need to begin
to work much more effectively
hand-in-hand with practitioners and with
patients because this like any other
industry needs to have ambassadors and
champions and it needs really respond to
the needs of the customers and in this
case be that practitioners patients or
oftentimes the payers involved we need
to make sure that these technologies are
being applied in ways that are really
going to be useful and that's going to
require a concerted effort I think by a
whole network of people and so a
three-dimensional biology of a cell is
an ecosystem just as I think bringing
that into practice is gonna take an eco
systems approach so in summary from
today if there's anything I'd like
people to walk away with it's maybe a
bit more of a visual appreciation if
nothing else that this biology is more
complex and and curious than perhaps our
medical technologies have been looking
to to appreciate that
changes in the configuration of a genome
within a cell are important that the
number of processes that go on to keep a
cell healthy and to divide a really a
very complicated almost industrial
aspect that is gonna require further
study but also appreciation and that to
bring that into the field I think some
new partnering approaches so with that
I'll just thank the group that I work
with day-in day-out who do a tremendous
job at trying to bring this concept into
clinical practice and I will open it up
for questions thank you
Thank You dr. Kevin little for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do sign up just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as you have time
for let's get started our first question
is does this technology compete with or
complement genomic sequencing test so I
I'm probably either wise enough or or
wizened enough to say I think complement
is probably the way to go
sequencing has been a fantastic
achievement and I and I don't mean to
diminish that in any way shape or form
it really is going to I think just be
increasingly important as complementary
information to help clinicians make
decisions and I see the three
dimensional appreciation of this as
being something that can also assist I
don't necessarily see some of the three
dimensional technologies is completely
doing away with sequencing by any by any
stretch of the imagination but I do
think that for particular indications
some of the work that we're doing in
Hodgkin's lymphoma for instance there
just simply is no biomarker there's no
sequence test identified that can help a
newly diagnosed Hodgkin's lymphoma
patient to know whether or not they're
going to respond to a first-line therapy
whereas being able to appreciate some of
the three-dimensional genomic aspects to
it leads to a test that's a piece of
information that complements sequencing
to some effect maybe replace the
sequencing in in others but really is
there as a tool for clinicians and I
think with each application of
technologies like ours we're seeing that
there's there's room for complementarity
thank you my next question
what are some of the challenges to
making this technology available to
clinicians and patients that's why is
that sort of alluded to it I think a lot
of the barriers to adoption are very
much around primarily awareness so
something like today is an attempt to to
begin to introduce this concept to get
people to start to appreciate the the
complexity of genomics in more than just
a two-dimensional linear sequence
there's been a wealth of information out
there about sequencing and about
genomics for quite some time I think
most clinicians being trained today have
a very strong appreciation for that I
think even the general public has a
significantly different level of of
Education and understanding of DNA and
of the genomes thanks to some of these
direct-to-consumer companies like
23andme so I've seen largely as
education outreach really trying to get
people to understand how these things
can be important it's up to us to help
people understand how it can be relevant
so I think outreach and and this
ecosystems approach are gonna be crucial
I would like to once again thank dr.
Kevin little for his presentation I
would also like to thank labrys for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through July of 2018 you'll receive an
email from lavage letting you know in
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
your colleagues who made a mess today's
live event let's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again